.
>>> WELCOME BACK NOW TO OUR
SPECIAL COVERAGE OF HURRICANE
IAN'S AFTERMATH.
WE DO WANT TO SHOW YOU SOME
STUNNING IMAGES.
THIS IS FROM THE SANIBEL
CAUSEWAY, JUST CAME IN MOMENTS
AGO, REALLY THE ONLY ACCESS BY
CAR TO SANIBEL ISLAND.
AND YOU CAN SEE THE APPROACH
THERE COLLAPSE.
A REAL SIGN OF THE POWER OF THE
WIND AND PARTICULARLY THE WATER
AND A LOT OF DAMAGE THERE,
POPPY, AS YOU LOOK AT THE REST
OF THOSE PICTURES ALONG THE REST
OF THAT LINE.
>> YEAH, THAT IS -- IF ANYONE
HAS DRIVEN ON THAT, IT'S
STUNNING TO SEE WHAT THIS STORM
DID, WHAT IAN DID THERE.
OUR REPORTER GAUGE GRADE
SCHOOLING FROM OUR AFFILIATE
WBBH WAS JUST THERE AT THE
SCENE.
I WANT YOU TO WATCH THIS.
>> I JUST WANT TO STEP OUT AND
JUST LET YOU TAKE THIS IN FOR A
SECOND.
THIS IS 50 FEET, APPROXIMATELY
50 TO 60, MAYBE 65 FEET OF THE
BRIDGE THAT HAS COLLAPSED INTO
THE GULF OF MEXICO DURING THE
HURRICANE IAN THAT WE
EXPERIENCED FOR THE LAST 48
HOURS HERE.
THIS IS A MONUMENTAL PIECE OF
THE BRIDGE.
I DON'T KNOW ANY OTHER WORD THAN
TO SAY MONUMENTAL PIECE OF THIS
BRIDGE THAT COLLAPSED.
AND PAUL, CAN WE ZOOM IN HERE TO
THIS ACTUAL PIECE OF ROADWAY?
THIS ONE HERE, YOU CAN STILL SEE
THE GUARD BARRIER, KIND OF THE
JERSEY BARRIER, IF YOU WILL, AND
YOU SEE THE CENTER LINE.
IT'S JUST LAYING IN THE GULF.
IT'S TRULY A BREATHTAKING SIGHT.
WHEREVER WE WALKED UP HERE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT, IT WAS
KIND OF LIKE ONE OF THOSE
MOMENTS WHEN YOU SAY, IT CAN'T
BE SO, IT CAN'T BE SO.
WE'RE BEING AS SAFE AS WE CAN.
PAUL, CAN YOU KIND OF LOOK DOWN
HERE AND JUST SHOW WHERE IT
CRUMBLED AND THE SAND AND THE
CONCRETE UNDERNEATH THIS BRIDGE
THAT ONCE HELD IT UP AND CARRIED
TRAVELERS, YOU AND ME, YOUR
LOVED ONES, YOUR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY AND ALL OF OUR FRIENDS
THAT VISIT US TO THE BEAUTIFUL
ISLANDS OF SANIBEL.
NOW, IT IS ENTIRELY COLLAPSED.
LOOK BACK THIS WAY, NOW THAT WE
HAVE SOME DAYLIGHT, IT'S MUCH
MORE TO TAKE IN.
LET'S LOOK AT THIS LIGHT POST.
IT IS ABOUT LEVEL TO MY EYES
RIGHT NOW, BUT IT IS ACTUALLY
SITTING ABOUT 20 FEET BELOW ME
IN THE GULF WATERS.
>> WOW, WOW.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S TALK TO THE COAST GUARD,
BECAUSE COAST GUARD OFFICIALS
SAY THAT THEY ARE PREPARED FOR A
VERY BUSY DAY OF SEARCH AND
RESCUE AHEAD ACROSS THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
YESTERDAY, FIRST RESPONDERS
RESCUED THIS PERSON TRAPPED IN A
FLOODED CAR.
THIS WAS IN NAPLES.
THIS MORNING, CREWS ARE PULLING
PEOPLE OFF OF ROOFS OF FLOODED
HOMES.
>> JOINING US NOW FROM FEMA
HEADQUARTERS HERE IN WASHINGTON,
D.C. IS VICE ADMIRAL PETE
GAUTIER, THE DEPUTY COMMANDANT
FOR OPERATIONS OF THE U.S. COAST
GUARD.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON, SIR.
THANKS FOR TAKING THE TIME.
>> THANKS, JIM AND POPPY.
>> YOUR TEAMS HAVE BEEN OUT IN
FORCE, COAST GUARD CREWS.
I WONDER HOW MANY RESCUES HAVE
YOU BEEN ABLE TO CARRY OUT IN
THE LAST 24 HOURS?
>> WELL, AS YOU MENTIONED, WE'VE
BEEN PREPARING FOR THIS STORM
FOR THE PAST WEEK.
WE'VE MOVED OUR COAST GUARD
CUTTERS AND BOATS AND
HELICOPTERS AND AIRCRAFT OUT OF
THE IMPACTED AREA AND WE'VE
MOBILIZED OTHERS FROM AROUND THE
COUNTRY TO BE PREPARED TO
QUICKLY COME IN BEHIND THIS
STORM, TO FIRST AND FOREMOST DO
RESCUES AND EVALUATE THE
SITUATION.
WE'VE DONE 23, RESCUED 23
INDIVIDUALS SO FAR, AND WE
EXPECT MANY MORE TO COME.
>> WE JUST HEARD GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS SAY THAT THIS IS A
500-YEAR FLOOD EVENT.
WE HEARD HIM SAY WE'VE NEVER
SEEN A STORM, A FLOODING EVENT
LIKE THIS.
AND SO, I WONDER, GIVEN THE
REPORTING WE'VE HEARD FROM
ANOTHER COMMANDER IN THE COAST
GUARD ABOUT PULLING PEOPLE OFF
OF ROOFS IN FT. MYERS AND
ELSEWHERE, WHAT ELSE DO YOU
EXPECT TO DO, ESPECIALLY IF WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THE WORST OF THE
FLOODING YET?
>> YEAH, RIGHT?
WELL, THE COAST GUARD DOES HAVE
EXPERIENCE FOR BETTER OR FOR
WORSE DOING SEARCH AND RESCUE
OVER LAND, URBAN SEARCH AND
RESCUE, AND DOING WHAT YOU
DESCRIBED.
HELPING PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
FLOODED AREAS, BOTH FROM THE
VERY HEAVY RAINS AND FROM THE
STORM SURGE THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED.
AND WE DO THIS VERY TIGHTLY
COORDINATED WITH THE NATIONAL
GUARD THERE IN FLORIDA.
AND OTHER FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE GOING TO BE
PARTICIPATING IN THIS FOR THE
DAYS TO COME.
BOTH ON LAND AND IN THE AIR, SO
I THINK WE CAN EXPECT FOR THE
FOLKS WHO DIDN'T EVACUATE, I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE
EXPECTING A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE GOING TO BE HOISTED OFF OF
ROOFS, A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO BE RESCUED ON THE
GROUND, AND WE'VE GOT A VERY
STRONG TEAM GOING FORWARD TO DO
THAT.
>> VICE ADMIRAL, WE'VE BEEN
SHOWING LIVE PICTURES AS WE'VE
BEEN SPEAKING TO YOU OF A HOUSE
ON FIRE IN FT. MYERS, FLORIDA.
IT SHOWS YOU ONE OF THE MANY
RISKS BEYOND THE WATER.
THERE ARE GAS LINES THERE ARE
CERTAINLY ACTIVE, ELECTRICAL
RISKS IN THE AREA THAT HAVEN'T
LOST POWER.
SOME STATE AND LOCAL RESCUE
CREWS, THEY'VE BEEN TELLING US
THAT THEY HAVE LIMITS AS TO WHEN
THEY CAN GO OUT.
IF THE WINDS EXCEED SAY 40 TO 45
MILES AN HOUR, THEY CAN'T GO OUT
FOR THE SAFETY OF THOSE CREWS.
I WONDER, DOES THE COAST GUARD
HAVE SIMILAR LIMITS AND CAN YOU
DESCRIBE WHAT YOUR CREWS FACED
LAST NIGHT CARRYING OUT THESE
RESCUES?
>> SURE.
OUR COAST GUARD CREWS DO HAVE
LIMITS, BUT THEY'RE PRETTY HIGH
LIMITS.
AND THEY DO A REALLY ROBUST RISK
EVALUATION BEFORE WE GO OUT.
WE STARTED FLYING LAST NIGHT
OVER THE FLORIDA KEYS OUT OF
MIAMI TO DO THE QUICK
EVALUATIONS IN THE AREAS, WHERE
THE LAST RAIN BANDS AND WIND
HAVE PASSED.
AND NOW WE'RE DOING THAT UP AND
INTO THE FT. MYERS AREA, IN THE
AREAS OF GREATEST IMPACT,
FOLLOWING THE TRACK LINE OF THIS
STORM.
SO WE CAN GET IN AND AMONGST THE
AREAS OF GREATEST DAMAGE TODAY
WITH THE LOCAL AND STATE AND
FEDERAL RESPONDERS SO WE CAN
RESCUE THE FOLKS THAT NEED
RESCUING.
WE CAN DO THE RAPID EVALUATIONS
TO UNDERSTAND WHERE THE HARD
WORK IN THE DAYS AND WEEKS AHEAD
ARE GOING TO BE.
AND PART OF THIS ACTUALLY IS WE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH PORT
AUTHORITIES AND FOCUSES IN THE
MARTIME TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM TO
CLOSE DOWN ALL THE MARITIME
TRANSPORTATION THERE ON THE WEST
SIDE OF FLORIDA AND WE'VE GOT TO
WORK HERE IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
DAYS TO MAKE SURE WE CAN OPENED
UP SAFELY IN THE NEXT FEW DAYS
TO COME.
>> VICE ADMIRAL, I WONDER HOW
WORRIED YOU ARE ABOUT THE FACT
THAT HURRICANE IAN REALLY
INTENSIFIED AS IT REACHED LAND.
AND THAT'S NOT USUALLY WHAT
HAPPENS WITH HURRICANES.
AND IT CERTAINLY IS NOT WHAT
HAPPENS IN TERMS OF THE RAPID
INTENSIFICATION THAT WE SAW IN
ALL OF THE STUDIES YOU LOOK AT
POINT TO CLIMATE CHANGE AS
BEING, YOU KNOW, A DRIVER AND A
CONTRIBUTOR TO THAT.
SO BEYOND THE DEVASTATION OF
IAN, I WONDER HOW CONCERNED YOU
ARE ABOUT WHAT IS NEXT, GIVEN
CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> WELL, WE'RE SEEING MORE
STORMS AT GREATER FREQUENCIES
AND IN HIGHER SEVERITY.
I THINK THIS IS A CASE IN
APPOINT.
ON THIS ONE, THE HISTORIC
NATURE, THE COMBINATION OF HEAVY
RAINS AND WINDS AND IT'S BEEN
VERY DEADLY.
IT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE TO LISTEN TO THEIR LOCAL
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS AND HEED
THE EVACUATION ORDERS.
THIS STORM WILL GO BACK INTO THE
ATLANTIC OCEAN AND HIT AGAIN.
THE FOLKS THERE NEED TO BE JUST
AS CAREFUL AND THIS ISN'T OVER
YET.
>> WE'RE ASKING EVERYONE,
BECAUSE THE EXTENT OF THE
DAMAGE, WE CAN SEE SOME FROM T
AIR, BUT IT'S HARD TO QUALIFY
FOR PEOPLE HOW MANY HOMES, HOW
MANY PEOPLE STILL IN NEED OF
RESCUE.
I WONDER BASED ON THE CALLS
YOU'RE GETTING, HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE IN DIRE NEED, BUT ALSO THE
EXTENT OF THE DEVASTATION ITEM
>> WELL, IT'S A VERY DYNAMIC
SITUATION RIGHT NOW, AND WE'VE
GOT TO REALIZE, WE'RE ONLY --
SUNRISE IS ONLY AN HOUR AND A
HALF AGO ON THE WEST COAST OF
FLORIDA THERE.
AND SO, WE'RE VERY MUCH IN THE
EARLY STAGES OF DOING THESE
EVALUATIONS, MOVING BACK IN,
TRYING TO NAVIGATE THE DAMAGED
STRUCTURE, THE DOWNED POWER
LINES AND SO ON IN ORDER TO GET
THERE AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN AND
RENDER ASSISTANCE.
BUT THIS IS GOING TO BE A LONG
RESPONSE AND THERE'S GOING TO BE
A LOT OF INFRASTRUCTURE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE AT THE FEMA
HEADQUARTERS.
THIS REALLY IS A TOTAL
INTERAGENCY SUPPORT RESPONSE.
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT FLORIDA.
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT THE
LOCALITIES.
THE COAST GUARD USES ITS OWN
AUTHORITIES TO DO SEARCH AND
RESCUE IN